[Música]
la red social china 'tik tok' y la
plataforma estadounidense de
entretenimiento o netflix suspendieron
sus servicios en territorio ruso la
decisión se une a la salida de otras
grandes compañías que durante los
últimos días han dejado de operar en
rusia debido a la invasión en ucrania
él ha acogido a cientos de migrantes
ucranianos que huyen de la guerra en su
país sin embargo el papel israelí en
este conflicto es delicado dado que sus
intereses ligan a la nación tanto a
rusia como ucrania
en la frontera entre méxico y eeuu
también se sienten las consecuencias de
este conflicto entre octubre de 2021 y
enero de 2022 6400 ciudadanos rusos
fueron detenidos en la frontera entre
ambos países en ese mismo plazo de
tiempo fueron detenidos más ciudadanos
ucranianos que en todo 2021 analizamos
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos esta emisión en
ucrania en donde tras el comienzo de la
invasión rusa el gobierno ucraniano
prohibió la salida del país a todos los
hombres de 18 a 60 años como
consecuencia a miles de personas se han
alistado de manera voluntaria para
combatir a las fuerzas rusas a pesar de
no contar con la experiencia suficiente
están convencidos de poder enfrentar a
los invasores rafael pérez nos trae más
detalles
preparación militar en medio de la
invasión bajo las bombas rusas un grupo
de voluntarios se alista el bid para
defender a ucrania
provienen de mundos diversos youtubers
blogueros cocineros e informáticos sin
experiencia militar
nunca he tenido un arma en mis manos ni
en el campo de tiro ni en ningún otro
lugar estoy en contra de la
militarización nunca me ha gustado
sin embargo anteponen el patriotismo
nuestra nación está unida como nunca
antes y todos saben que debemos defender
y luchar por nuestro país por nuestra
tierra
forlán según la guardia nacional más de
100.000 personas se han ofrecido como
voluntarios desde el inicio de la
campaña rusa en los entrenamientos
aprenden lo necesario para sobrevivir en
el crudo escenario de la guerra ya que
las bananas astro del deporte les
enseñamos como no dispararse a sí mismo
ni a los soldados ucranianos de peleas
callejeras pueden quitarle el arma a un
ruso muerto
a pesar de la prisa y las condiciones
poco propicias de los entrenamientos los
voluntarios terminan seguros de poder
enfrentar al enemigo y ya no estaré
listo pero lo haré en este contexto el
ejército ucraniano se alista para un
posible avance ruso hacia kiev las
fuerzas militares se levantan barricadas
en las carreteras que conducen a la
capital del país abren trincheras y
establecen puntos de control armados
para dificultar el paso de las fuerzas
invasoras
la red social china 'tik tok' y la
plataforma estadounidense de
entretenimiento netflix suspendieron sus
servicios para usuarios de rusia la
decisión de las icónicas plataformas se
une a la salida masiva de grandes
compañías que durante los últimos días
han dejado de operar en ese país debido
a la invasión en ucrania juan pabló
lucumí tiene más detalles
más compañías internacionales retiran su
servicio de rusia ahora la plataforma de
streaming estadounidense netflix y la
red social china tick tock también
suspenderán sus operaciones en suelo
ruso una decisión que llega después de
que la duma aprobara una ley que puede
dar hasta 15 años de cárcel para quienes
difundan lo que el kremlin considere
como información falsa sobre las
acciones de sus fuerzas armadas en
ucrania tick tock es una salida para la
creatividad y el entretenimiento que
puede proporcionar una fuente de alivio
y conexión humana durante un tiempo de
guerra en el que la gente se enfrenta a
una inmensa tragedia y aislamiento sin
embargo la seguridad de nuestros
empleados y nuestros usuarios sigue
siendo nuestra máxima prioridad netflix
que llevaba un poco más de un año rusia
y contaba apenas con un millón de
suscriptores en este país ha mencionado
que no tiene intención de cumplir con la
nueva ley audiovisual del parlamento
ruso que obligaría a la plataforma a
incluir un paquete de canales públicos
afiliados al kremlin para poder operar
en el país como channel one y la cadena
de la iglesia ortodoxa debido a las
circunstancias que hay sobre el terreno
hemos decidido suspender nuestro
servicio en rusia la ley de la duma que
arremete contra la libertad de expresión
ya ha causado que más de siete medios
internacionales dejen de informar en
rusia y ha generado una salida masiva de
grandes compañías internacionales del
entretenimiento la moda la tecnología y
multinacionales de servicios financieros
israel acogió a cientos de inmigrantes
ucranianos que huyen de la guerra no
obstante el país el papel de este país
en el conflicto es delicado y por ello
ha evitado pronunciarse contundentemente
ya que sus intereses ligan a la nación
tanto a rusia como a ucrania a alva
santana no es amplia
tras una larga y difícil travesía para
muchos cientos de ucranianos llegaron a
israel en busca de un nuevo hogar
estoy feliz estoy muy emocionada estoy
cansada siento que estoy en un lugar
seguro y que mucha gente está
esperándonos
pero a pesar de que el gobierno israelí
ya ha dicho que espera recibir cerca de
200.000 refugiados ucranianos el papel
de israel en este conflicto no es nada
fácil el país de mayoría judía tiene
fuertes vínculos tanto con rusia como
con ucrania de hecho israel acoge a
aproximadamente 12 millones de ruso
parlantes procedentes de los países que
conformaban la antigua unión soviética
lo que supone un 12 por ciento del
electorado con ucrania donde residen
cerca de 200 mil judíos hay mayor
afinidad ideológica y hay grandes lazos
culturales incluso el presidente
volodymyr selenski es judío pero cortar
relaciones con rusia es complicado para
israel ya que las tropas rusas en síria
cercanas al gobierno de bachar al asad
permiten la entrada en el país a los
israelíes para ejecutar operaciones
militares contra el grupo hezbollah una
situación que hay al ejecutivo de
naftalí bennett a ofrecerse como
mediador tras una reunión sorpresa con
vladimir putin
aunque la posibilidad no sea grande en
cuanto haya una mínima apertura y
tengamos acceso a todas las partes y
capacidades considero que es nuestra
obligación moral hacer todo lo posible
por mediar las soft colonization no
obstante pese a esta voluntad de
imparcialidad muchos israelíes ya han
tomado un bando el de los ucranianos con
multitareas protestas en tel aviv contra
la invasión rusa y pidiendo un mayor
posicionamiento del gobierno algo con lo
que eeuu que anualmente proporciona
miles de millones de israel en ayuda
extranjera también está presionando
las consecuencias de este conflicto y de
la escalada de tensión anterior a la
invasión rusa han llegado también a la
lejana frontera entre méxico y eeuu
entre octubre de 2021 y enero de 2022
6400 ciudadanos rusos fueron detenidos
en los más de 3.000 kilómetros de
frontera entre ambos países en ese mismo
plazo de tiempo fueron detenidos más
ciudadanos ucranianos que en todo 2021
para analizar esta realidad pudimos
hablar anteriormente con alma yunís
rendón cárdenas doctora en sociología
política y políticas públicas por el
instituto de estudios políticos de parís
rendón nos contó cómo puede afectar esta
nueva ola migratoria a los migrantes
especialmente centroamericanos que ya se
encuentran en la frontera bueno pues
justamente en este momento en la
frontera de méxico con estados unidos
tenemos a los solicitantes de refugio en
eeuu es decir a todos los
centroamericanos que están solicitando
esta figura humanitaria en eeuu están
hoy esperando en mexico por el programa
the remaining méxico o permanece en
mexico que desafortunadamente a pesar de
que bardem no había cancelado calificado
como inhumano al principio de su mandato
la suprema corte justicia lo obliga a
reiniciarlo y bueno ahí lo tenemos ya
desde hace tres meses de nuevo en seis
puntos fronterizos esto además aunado a
todos los retornos por título 42 que nos
han hecho es decir diariamente dejan a
personas de centroamérica en la frontera
mexicana con el pretexto de la pandemia
y del peligro de la salud pública para
los estadounidenses y bueno ahora vamos
a sumarle a estos ucranianos y rusos que
lleguen también y qué bueno intenten
ingresar incluso se ha hablado que
algunos han conseguido autos chocolate
que son estos autos sin placas para
poder ingresar de manera más rápida en
fin yo creo que va a detonar varias
problemáticas pero bueno sí creo que se
va a dar una respuesta más inmediata a
estos ciudadanos que a todos los que ya
venían esperando antes en eeuu medios
informaron que altos funcionarios del
gobierno viajaron a venezuela para
reunirse con funcionarios del país con
el que rompieron relaciones diplomáticas
en 2019 la reunión llega en un momento
en que washington busca aislar a rusia
de sus principales aliados siendo
venezuela su principal apoyo en el
continente americano además de un país
productor de petróleo y hablando del oro
negro el barril de brent araña los 140
dólares cerca de su máximo histórico
y en la ciudad estadounidense de san
francisco decenas de personas se
reunieron para pedir la paz en ucrania
allí recrearon la obra una paloma ha
extendido sus alas y pide paz del
artista ucraniana maryna maría primas en
coco con estas imágenes nos despedimos
sigan conectados con nosotros en france
[Música]